what's up world i am comedian joel byers
and after 10 years in stand-up comedy
and over 200 interviews with comics on
my hop breath podcast
i'm here to share with you the most
helpful
comedy books that every comic needs to
read high breath
so first things first
you gotta learn the fundamentals and i'm
a comedian
not a videographer not a fancy youtuber
i'm just here to give you the raw
information about the books you need to
level up your comedy
so the first out of the gate greg dean
step by step to stand up comedy and i'm
not sponsored by him this was just the
first book
i've read you could tell by how
weathered it is this is the first
book i ever read cover to cover in
standup comedy
over 10 years ago and this is a great
book
to learn the fundamentals of stand-up
comedy it really breaks down
one-liners specifically and how to
organize and the mechanism of
taking an idea and formulating it
into a one-liner joke he has a really
good system for that which is where i
started i do more storytelling
a little more of a a conversational
approach to my stand up now but it all
started with learning the rules because
you got to learn the rules before you
can break them
this is a great place to learn the rules
of joke writing
as well as rehearsing your set preparing
your set
this is just a really good resource for
where do i even
start type deal so this by the way
is linked in the comments with all the
other books i'm going to talk about
today
but hang out with me till the end and
i'm going to share an opportunity to
where you can actually get all these
books for free
as well so the second one
out the gate steve martin
born standing up not only is steve
martin my favorite comic
but he has blazed the trail for so many
of us comics
not only from just being successful
outside of stand-up
in terms of i mean his music career he's
a writer he's a director he's so much
more than a stand-up comic
but he was actually the first comic to
start selling out arenas
and really put stand-up comedy on that
next level
from a business standpoint and what's
interesting
as we talk about uh this book breaking
down the fundamentals
of joke writing how to you know um
set up punch misdirect the audience
steve martin's approach to comedy was
actually
the absence of a punchline and he talks
about in his
book how he started to find comedy in
the
absence of structure in the absence of
a formula within comedy which i think
really
is what made him stand out from the
comedy at the time
was him looking at what's popular and
how can i do the opposite and make that
even more popular
and this book is not only just about his
process it's about
the early struggles of being a comedian
seriously
in san francisco performing in front of
a window to get people to come into the
empty venue he was performing at
so many amazing stories and this is
known in the comedy community as a must
read by the most well respected comics
in the game
this book gives you the most realistic
brutally honest transparent
just raw reality that is
the pursuit of stand-up comedy you know
um
even jerry seinfeld says on the cover
right here absolutely magnificent one of
the best books about comedy
and being a comedian ever written and
that's from jerry seinfeld
and this is coming from joel byers as
well which is me
and you probably forgot already
but it's all good steve martin's born
standing up a must read for anyone
that wants to pursue comedy as their
profession
and take it seriously must read and the
audiobook is really good because steve
actually reads it as well
check it out the next one
i killed when we're talking about
reality
okay and how steve martin's book gives
you that raw reality of
the early days of stand-up starting out
in stand-up and he traces his career to
the immense success
and his eventual um hiatus from stand up
and i say hiatus because i do feel like
he he i hope he comes back and then he
can come on
my hop breath podcast and we can talk
about it together
but this book i killed another must read
from um this was compiled by rich
schneider and mark schiff
but what i actually was looking for is
the forward is written by
jerry seinfeld this is this is that raw
reality that we're talking about of life
on the road
every comic and in my podcast the number
one question i ask i always ask
you know their favorite advice for
comics
but i also ask their worst show
their worst booze story their worst
bombing their most unforgettable
experience
in comedy and everyone has these
experiences everyone has these crazy
moments on stage
and this book compiles
those moments from some of the best i
mean just look at the cover chris rock
jay leno
larry the cable guy jeff foxworthy i
mean
the best of the best tell their stories
of the worst of the worst
of their shows in this book so it's a
very entertaining read
but it's also very insightful in terms
of
what am i getting myself into here as a
comedian
and this is why and maybe a big reason
why so many comics are trying to blow up
on the internet instead of getting blown
up while performing
for you know four people at a show they
drove
five hours to make five dollars that the
booker said they don't have
that's the reality i i've driven 12
hours one way
for a show we all we all do these
we all do these gigs as comedians and
this is a
fun entertaining look into that side
of stand up and the final book
and remember if you are enjoying this
video if you do enjoy this channel do go
ahead and subscribe
and um support what we're building here
which is
the hot breath comedy network where we
are cultivating the next generation of
great comics
and the final book
finding your funny the comics playbook
this is actually a book
that i wrote with mit alum
dr robert joseph and this is really a
joke writing handbook there's a lot of
books with formulas but i've found that
when you write your jokes in a formula
you start to sound formulaic you start
to deliver
with that rigidity of a formula so i
wanted to design this book
with the voice in mind and every comic
wants to find their voice so i really
designed this book to help comics find
their voice giving them exercises to not
only
generate those personal emotional ideas
but then how to formulate them into
jokes
and organize them into a tight
five-minute set
so this is going to be a great manual
for that that you can have as a resource
it's a friendly reminder there's a lot
of helpful exercises in here that i wish
i had
starting out in comedy over 10 years ago
and it's a fun dynamic because i'm
coming out from the approach as a
professional comedian
but uh dr robert joseph is actually an
aspiring comedian
who also has an extremely extremely
educated math background so we're able
to find
the structure behind these ideas of
finding emotion but then how do you
formulate that into the language of
comedy
so this one's super helpful as well but
all four of these are really going to
help you
in your comedy career whether it is from
the skill
side of it or whether it is from just
the reality side
of it of what am i getting myself into
these books are going to give you a
realistic expectation and what it comes
down to is the work
i've interviewed over 200 comics you
name it cedric the entertainer
mark normand dan soder tommy davidson
it's there's over 200 interviews i've
done and they're all
on wherever you listen to your favorite
podcast and they're all on this youtube
channel as well
and the number one piece of advice has
been you you gotta get on stage
you gotta do the work so all these books
are going to help you add perspective
add structure to your jokes and things
like that but you see i'm trying to fan
them out
coach i'm not a youtuber i'm a comic but
what you need the most you got to put it
to work none of this will work unless
you work
so and that comes down to getting on
stage
so if you'd like an opportunity to
actually get all four of these books for
free
i love helping comics that's what hot
breath is all about that's that's my
whole mission
in stand-up comedy i love helping comics
learn from the mistakes i've made so
what i wanted to do
as a helpful resource is share
a giveaway to where it's linked in the
comments
where you can get the opportunity to get
all four of these books for free and if
you're watching this
after the fact there is also links to
get these books
as well if the giveaway is over because
this is a limited time giveaway
but i really wanted to create a video
that i wish existed when i started
comedy
about where do i begin what are some
helpful resources
so these four books are really gonna be
helpful resources throughout your entire
comedy career
you know what to do you've seen enough
youtube videos there's a description you
click a link
fill out the information for the
giveaway and i will mail you
these four books thanks
so if you enjoy learning about stand-up
comedy you are going to
love hot breath podcast subscribe to
this youtube channel
keep up with our weekly videos and keep
grinding kids
good luck
you